In this problem, we're looking
at a two stage process in
which the first stage, we roll
a fair die which has four
faces to obtain a number N,
where N belongs to the set 0,
1, 2, and 3 with equal
probability.
Now, given the result of the die
roll, N will toss a fair
coin N times in getting K heads
from the coin tosses.
For instance, if from the first
die roll, we get N equal
to 3, then we'll toss
a coin 3 times.
Let's say the outcome is heads,
heads, and tails.
And that will give
us K equal to 2.
For part A, we're asked to
compute the PMF for N, which
is a result of the
first die roll.
Now, since we had assumed the
die roll was uniformly
distributed in the set in the
set 0, 1, 2, and 3, we have
that the chance of N being equal
to any little n is equal
to 1/4 if n is in the set 0,
1, 2, 3, and 0 otherwise.
If we were to plot this in
a figure, we'll have the
following plot.
For part B, things are getting
a little more complicated.
This time, we want to compute
the joint PMF between N and K
for N equal to little n and
K equal to little k.
What we'll do first is to use
the law of conditional
probability to break the joint
probability into the product
of probability of K is equal to
little k conditional on N
is equal to little n, multiply
by the probability that N is
equal to little n.
Now, the second term right here
is simply the PMF of N,
which will be computed
earlier.
So this gives us 1/4 times
probability K equal to little
k, N equal to little n,
for all N in the set
0, 1, 2, and 3.
Now, clearly if N is not one
of those four values, this
whole event couldn't have
happened in the first place,
and hence will have P
and K equal to 0.
We'll now go over all the cases
for little n in this
expression right here.
The first case is
the simplest.
If we assume that little n is
equal to 0, that means the die
roll was 0, and hence we're
not tossing any coins
afterwards.
And this implies that we must
have K is equal to 0, which,
mathematically speaking,
is equivalent to saying
probability of K equal
to 0 conditional on N
equal to 0 is 1.
And K being any other value
conditional N equal to 0 is 0.
So we're done with the case that
little n is equal to 0.
Now, let's say little n is
in the set 1, 2, and 3.
In this case, we want to notice
that after having
observed the value of N, all
the coin tosses for N times
are conditionally independent
from each other.
What this means is now the total
number of heads in the
subsequent coin toss is equal in
distribution to a binomial
random variable with parameter
n and 1/2.
And here says the number of
trials is n, and 1/2 is
because the coin is fair.
And the reason it is a binomial
random variable,
again, is because the coin
tosses are independent
conditional on the outcome
of the die roll.
And now we're done, since we
know what the binomial
distribution looks like given
parameter n and 1/2.
And we'll simply substitute
based on the case of n the
conditional distribution of K
back into the product we had
earlier, which in turn will
give us the joint PMF.
This table summarizes the PMF
we were computing earlier.
P of N, K, little
n, and little k.
Now, as we saw before, if
n equal to 0, the only
possibility for k
is equal to 0.
And this is scaled by the
probability of n equal to 0,
which is 1/4.
For any other values of n, we
see that the distribution of
k, conditional n, is the same as
a binomial random variable
with n trials.
And again, every entry here
is scaled by 1/4.
And this completes part B.
In part C, we're asked for
the conditional PMF of K
conditioning on the value
of N being equal to 2.
Now, as we discussed in part B,
when N is equal to 2, we're
essentially flipping a fair coin
twice, and this should
give us the same distribution as
a binomial random variable
with parameter 2 and 1/2.
Now, 2 is the number of flips,
and 1/2 is the chance of
seeing a head in each flip.
And that gives us the following
distribution.
But there's another
way to see this.
It's to write P K given N,
little k, and you go to 2 by
using the law of conditional
probability as P K, N, the
joint PMF, k n2, divided by
the probability that N is
equal to 2.
Now, we know that probability n
equal to 2 is simply 1/4, so
this gives us 4 times the joint
density K, N, k, 2.
In other words, in order to
arrive at the distribution
right here, [INAUDIBLE]
to go back to the table we had
earlier and look at the role
where n is equal to 2 and
multiply each number by 4.
Finally, in part D, we're asked
for the conditional
distribution of N, write as
P N, given K of N equal to
little n conditional
on K is equal to 2.
Again, we'll apply the formula
for conditional probability.
This is equal to the joint PMF
evaluated at n and 2 divided
by the probability of
K being equal to 2.
Since we have computed the
entire table of the joint PMF,
this shouldn't be
too difficult.
In particular, for the
denominator, the probability
that k is ever equal to
2, we just look at the
column right here.
So the entries in this column
shows all the cases where k
can be equal to 2.
And in fact, we can see that k
can be equal to 2 only if n is
equal to 2 or 3.
Clearly, if you toss the coin
fewer than 2 times, there's no
chance that we'll get 2 heads.
So to get this probability right
here, we'll add up the
number in these two cells.
So we get P N, K, little
n, and 2 divided
by 1/16 plus 3/32.
Now, the numerator, again, can
be read off from the table
right here.
In particular, this tells us
that there are only two
possibilities.
Either n is equal to
2 or n equal to 3.
When n is equal to 2, we know
this quantity gives us 1/16
reading off this cell divided
by 1/16 plus 3/32
for n equal to 2.
And the remaining probability
goes to the case where n is
equal to 3.
So this is 3 divided by 32,
1/16 plus 3/32, which
simplifies to 2/5 and 3/5.
And this distribution gives
us the following plot.
And this completes our problem.